[Music]
so uh what are you dating like an
accountant now Ellen ventriloquist stop
you love a dummy this is not why we're
here
[Music]
I know I were here a rescue op save the
dinosaurs from island that's about to
explode
what could go wrong
blue is alive you raised her do these
animals deserve the same protections
given to other species or should they
just be left to die these creatures were
here before us
if we're not careful
we're gonna be here after
you know me
[Music]
life cannot be contemned life breaks
free life finds away
[Music]
I have a dream a song to see I'm so glad
you're here
I'm pregnant but I don't know how to do
this by myself
your mother is the bravest person we
ever meet my baby
let me tell you how she did it all on
her own
[Music]
by short the world is wide
I want to make some memories
this dress might look very pretty on you
you don't know me at all do you
[Music]
I think we should stay here together I
wish I could stay it turns out he's
engaged I hate it when they do that I
was cheated by you think you know me now
will I ever learn I don't know how but I
suddenly lose control there's a fire
within my soul closer to my mom she
wasn't scared because she had me
we can't tell anybody else about the
baby okay
I just told bill and I told Harry I told
many many people let's get the party
started grandma you weren't invited
that's the best kind of party little
girl for Doug and his best friend Han na
every day was great
moody Barry mr. roat coming hunting
today wouldn't miss it for the world
and every night was a party until the
day everything changed
to the Badlands the edge of stone is
over long live the edge of bronze
how are we gonna get overly back
[Music]
let's again commence
[Music]
we challenge the champions a caveman
caveman you took all hope
if we win you leave my tribe in peace
what an idea you think you can beat Rael
bronzy oh I can help if we play this
game and beat them at it we can have our
Valley back
[Applause]
what happens if you kick the ball in the
goal then other men hug and kiss you oh
you're losers caveman always I've been
always will be
[Music]
if we work together we may just stand a
chance
we're still a try
[Applause]
no we always hunt rabbits couldn't we
try hunting something bigger suena
morning say four five we gotta talk
about what's happening in Chicago
everybody's watching this viral video
this guy in a hoodie they're calling the
Grim Reaper stop the carjacking is he
right for taking the law into his own
hands
he's become a folk hero what about the
shooter the men who did it
are out there so there's nothing that we
can do is that what you're saying if a
man really wants to protect force his I
want to buy a gun
he has to do is for himself I believe
you Joe you're not gonna kill me no
jackass
you got caught in some crossfire dice
the ice-cream man can't walk to school
if they don't work for you were you the
last customer here cock-blocked and
paperwork I'll say they called him
Authority names
[Music]
you look much better
getting out socializing hmm not so much
well whatever you're doing keep it up
okay I will
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
snacks coming into a clock gentlemen
[Music]
thank you sir
shut the heck
[Applause]
[Music]
once you begin to discover who you are
then you really realize how you have
been given authority over your life
[Music]
it was a struggle of life and
most people go to write for boarding
[Music]
[Applause]
on a dream at some point in time a
transition takes place
[Music]
in you but
go with him
taking the shortcuts do
[Music]
for this great work
I don't know man you ever just feel like
life is just pushing us toward something
like some greater purpose
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the japanese archipelago'
20 years in the future canine saturation
has reached epidemic proportions an
outbreak of dog flu rips through the
city of mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exiled colony the Isle
of Dogs I don't think I can stomach any
more of this garbage nobody's giving up
around here and don't you forget it
ever your Rex your king your Duke your
boss I'm chief
we're a pack of scary indestructible
alpha dogs Atari Kobayashi you
heroically hijacked a junior turboprop
XJ 750 and flew it to the islands
because of the dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him little
pilot why should I
because he's a 12 year old boy dogs love
those we'll find him wherever he is if
he's alive we'll find your dog it's
gonna be a fight
[Music]
or somebody spoke his language
to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
great get ready to jump
Romeo and Juliet are moving to a whole
new garden all clear not quite perfect
but it's ours think of all the
adventures we're gonna have me oh man
Katie that is just are you done a minute
the quiz humans coming purges everyone
they were supposed to live happily ever
after but when their world is in danger
Judea the gnomes there's only one knows
except for the one you all an adventure
we have to get to cross that River you
need a ship no [ __ ] Sherlock
you've got a great unknown hey our next
clue is in the park directions quickly
just follow the blue line on the ground
until you find the giant red Suns
MacAvoy and we block to Attila geoff for
mary j blige and Johnny Depp with
original music by Elton John and Bernie
Taupin
they have to go in to come out let's go
to forward hold o ho forgive me I've
never been the back end of a swirl
before
a lot knows that's not how a squirrel
fixit's behind mankini can you
demonstrate Julie you see yes they're
acting like a rear end
[Music]
working for the fan
[Music]
you cup not exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how are you I'm Mary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for over a century the hotel has been
his life
next summer
anyone
drag
[Music]
oh you keep of a full-service spa yeah
so impressive it's like a hotel on the
water
[Music]
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right
yet to fail all the same
[Applause]
read it
run from it destiny still arrived
[Music]
evacuate the city
and gates our defenses
and get this manna shoot
[Music]
on isn't something one considers
imbalance in the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
[Music]
the hell are you guys
[Music]
[Music]